in 1901 the english philosopher and
mathematician bertrand russell
discovered a problem a paradox at the
heart of mathematics and all of science
the paradox specifically concerns a
foundational branch of mathematics
called set theory so in this lecture i
teach you all of set theory in like
eight minutes and then i show how the
paradox arises russell himself and many
other mathematicians thought that they
could solve this paradox but
i argue that they can't and they don't
so let's get started what is a number
take for example the number four
i'm not talking about four potatoes or
four tomatoes or four
hairs i'm talking about the number four
itself we know lots of things about the
number four like that it is evenly
divisible by two and that it's the
square root of sixteen i think
i'm talking about the number itself and
i'm also not talking about this right
here this is not the number four this
is the arabic numeral written on a piece
of glass the arabic numeral that
represents the number four we have other
numerals that represent numbers like
this one
that's the roman numeral four we use it
for counting super bowls here in the
united states the number itself is
something that no one has ever seen or
touched but we seem to know things about
and also it and every other number is
essential to science technology and all
of human life immanuel kant was a
prussian philosopher living in the 1700s
this painting of him was actually done
in color but i've changed it to black
and white to make it seem even older he
thought that mathematics was a
construction of the human mind and if
that's right then mathematical truths
are in some sense or rather subjective
but the german and english philosophers
gottlob fraga and bertrand russell
didn't like this they thought that
mathematics had to be objective to
refute and counteract kant's view
they developed a view called logicism
according to logicism mathematics is a
branch of logic and the most basic type
of
math which is arithmetic
could be reduced to just
first order basic logic and set theory
i'll explain what set theory is in a
second they thought that if they could
succeed in reducing arithmetic to logic
and set theory then they would be able
to answer this question what is a number
and the answer would be that numbers are
sets okay well what is a set a set is a
collection of objects the branch of
mathematics that studies sets or
collections of objects was invented by
the russian german mathematician georg
cantor in the 1870s cantor proved that
some infinities were larger than other
infinities yes that's right the idea is
that you could have an infinite number
of something and then an infinite number
of something else but that you'd have
more of one than the other yes it's wild
in order to do this he had to invent set
theory and so now i'm going to teach you
set theory very quickly but then set
theory is going to run into a terrible
problem it's going to seem terrible
they're going to try to solve it but
then i'm going to show that they didn't
really solve it
the version of set theory that i'm going
to explain to you in the next few
minutes is naive set theory
it's called naive just because it's the
ordinary set theory that we can
formulate in ordinary languages like
english and it's contrasted with formal
or axiomatic set theory which is
formulated in an artificial logical
language you don't have to worry about
any of that a set is a collection of
objects like the set of these markers
there are three markers here and the set
of these markers contains three items
within it but the objects in a set don't
need to be collected together in space
or time in order to be a set for the
purposes of set theory so on the one
hand we could have the set of those
three markers but we could also have the
set of all of the people watching this
video who are spread out all over the
world maybe they're spread out
throughout time moreover the objects in
a set don't need to be related to each
other in any significant or meaningful
way another set could be the set of
lebron james the four-time nba champion
and the top half of the eiffel tower
these things have nothing to do with
each other really but we have a set with
those two things in them those two
members those two items anything that we
can refer to anything that we can
imagine that can be in a set we could
have a set that consists of lebron james
the four-time nba champion and harry
potter the young wizarding boy who does
not exist that set contains those two
objects one of which has won an nba
championship four times as of the
recording of this video and the other
one is a non-existent boy with magic
powers indeed sets can even include
objects that can't be imagined we could
have the set of all objects that cannot
be imagined that's a set too and it
contains many many things perhaps an
infinite number of things things that
can't be imagined you see these squiggly
brackets the squiggly brackets are used
in set theory to pick out the set and
all the stuff inside those brackets are
the stuff in the set so this is the set
of lebron james and the number four
there are two things in this set a
number and a basketball player on this
form of notation in order to pick out a
set in writing we would have to write
out all of the things that are in that
set but that's too clumsy if it's a big
set like the set of all cats the set of
all cats includes many many things too
many cats to list out and also we don't
even know all the names of all the cats
all the cats in the world all the cats
in the universe so instead we use this
notation which is red as follows the set
of all x's such that x is a cat that's
called the set builder or intentional
notation you don't have to remember that
the other crucial thing is the word
contains we say that a set contains
all of the objects that are members of
that set so this set from before
contains lebron james and the number
four the set of all cats contains
garfield and all the other cats as well
a set is a many that allows itself to be
thought of as a one gay or cantor never
said that someone just said that he said
that but he didn't really say it a set
is a gathering together into a hole of
definite distinct objects of our
perception or of our thought which are
called elements of the set he did really
say that but he said it in german when
cantor invented set theory in the 1870s
he wasn't just making up a mathematical
game for the sake of it no no we deal
with sets every day suppose that someone
says that pile of potatoes is enormous
they're not talking about the individual
potatoes they're not saying the
individual potatoes are enormous some of
them may be quite large but some of them
are small like fingerling potatoes i'm
gonna try to find a photo of a
fingerling potato or some other kinds of
potatoes anyway when we say that that
pile of potatoes is enormous we're
talking about the pile not the
individual potatoes and we do the same
thing with objects that are not
collected together spatially the world
population of cats is enormous the cats
aren't collected together in space but
we're talking about all of the cats as a
whole and we're saying that that
population is enormous we're not saying
that the individual cats are enormous
although some of them might be quite
hefty the paradox the logical problem
that russell discovers in 1901 concerns
one or more of the rules of set theory
so let's go through some rules real
quick before we can get to the paradox
rule number one
unrestricted composition that just means
we can make any sets we want any set
that you can think of that's a set in
the formal axiomatized version of set
theory this is called the axiom of
unrestricted comprehension you don't
have to remember that
rule number two set identity is
determined by membership what does this
mean it means that what makes a certain
set the set that it is is just what's
inside of it it doesn't matter how we
label that stuff it doesn't matter how
we label the whole set as a whole all
that matters is what's in the set
informal axiomatized set theory this is
called the axiom of extensionality you
do not have to remember that rule number
three the order of elements in a set
doesn't matter
here for example our two sets the set of
the number one and the number two
and the set of the number two and the
number one these two sets are the same
set because the order that you put the
items in the objects it doesn't matter
now you can see this rule this really
comes from number two number two says
that set identity is determined by
membership all that matters is who's a
member or what items are a member of the
set it doesn't matter the order rule
number four repeats don't change
anything
this set right here which contains the
number one the number two and the number
two is exactly the same set that we were
talking about five seconds ago it's the
set of just the numbers one and two if
you repeat a number or a member of a set
it doesn't change the set because set
identity is determined by membership
that's rule number four which is really
just derived from rule number two rule
number five the description of the items
in a set doesn't matter for example the
set that contains just lebron james and
the set that contains all x's all things
such that that thing is the nba all-time
scoring leader playoffs included i'm
including the playoffs if you only talk
about the regular season then kareem
abdul-jabbar as of this recording is
still the all-time points leader but if
you include regular season and playoffs
then it's already lebron james those two
sets are the same set it doesn't matter
if you describe him as lebron james or
king james or the nba all-time scoring
leader either way it's the same set
containing the same one item in it and
that's that guy who's a basketball
player rule number six the union of any
two or more sets is itself a set this
rule just means that if you take two
sets like the set of all cats and the
set of all dogs and you combine them and
then you've got the set of all cats and
dogs well that's a set too this rule
number six comes from rule number one
because rule number one says you could
just make any sets you want so if you
got two sets
and then you put them together that's
another set you can make that one too
rule seven any subset is a set a subset
is just a set containing some of the
items that are contained in another set
and that comes from rule one two if you
can make any set then any set you've got
well any group of those items in there
that's a subset that's a set two rule
eight a set can have just one member
this set contains one item or one
element and that is lebron james
four-time nba champion a set with just
one member is called a singleton set one
important thing to notice is that this
set this singleton set
is not the same as lebron james
lebron james is a four-time nba champion
this set the singleton set containing
lebron james is a zero time nba champion
it has never won an nba championship and
it has never played a game of basketball
because it is a set this rule rule
number eight also derives from rule
number one if we can make any set that
we want well then we can make a set with
just one item in it
okay we are approaching the point where
one of these rules is going to generate
the paradox it's going to blow the whole
thing up hold on it's coming rule number
nine a set can have no members
this set is called the empty set you can
write it like this with just the
squiggles and nothing in between or you
can signify it with this which is a like
a zero with a line through it which
means nothing this is an empty set the
empty set or it's called the null set
the fact that there can be such a set
just derives from rule number one
unrestricted composition you can make
any sets you want including a set with
nothing in it but it is derived from
number two that set identity is
determined by membership that there's
only one empty set or only one null set
that one set with nothing in it it's
defined by the fact that it has nothing
in it so if you have two sets and
they're both empty they're the same set
the null set
now things get juicy
rule number 10 you can have sets of sets
this just follows from number one as
well if you can make a set out of
anything that you can think of well you
can think of sets too can't you sets can
have sets in them for example the set of
all singleton sets you'd write it like
this which reads the set of all x's such
that x is a singleton set that is a set
of all sets it contains the set that
just includes lebron james it contains
the set that just includes the number
17. it does not contain lebron james
because this is the set of all singleton
sets and lebron james is not a singleton
set he's not a set at all he's a
four-time nba champion or you could have
the set of all sets the set of all x's
such that x is a set this by the way is
how fragile and russell answered that
question from before what are numbers
they thought at least they thought until
russell's paradox just blew the whole
thing up they thought that the number
one just is
the set of all singleton sets the set of
all sets with one member and the number
two just is the set of all sets with two
members now you might be thinking i
can't wrap my head around this what does
it really mean for the number four to
just be
a certain set what does what does that
really mean don't worry no one really
understands what that means not really
anyway it doesn't matter because the
whole thing is going to be blown up
right now with the next rule which is
rule number 11.
sets can contain themselves this one's
weird and it's going to give us the
paradox but
that just comes from rule number one
also if you can if you can think of it
you can throw it in a set and so you can
think of sets and so you can throw sets
in themselves consider for example the
set of all cats does that set contain
itself no because that set is not itself
a cat it's a set and everything in it is
a cat so it does not contain itself what
about the set of all sets the set of all
x's such that x is a set does that set
contain itself yes that set contains all
the sets and it is itself one of those
sets so it contains itself or
the set of all the things that i'm
thinking about this set doesn't usually
contain itself but right now it does
because right now i'm thinking of that
set let's follow the pattern of thought
that russell was following in 1901 and
1902 when he discovered this paradox he
was just thinking about and developing
this idea rule number 11 that sets can
contain themselves think about all the
sets that do not contain themselves the
singleton set with just lebron james
does it contain itself no because it
just has one thing in there and that's
lebron not any sets let alone itself the
set of all cats doesn't contain itself
because it itself is a set not a cat the
set of all singleton sets does that set
contain itself no because there are a
lot of singleton sets and so the set of
all singleton sets has a lot of sets in
it and so it is itself not a singleton
set it's got many many members many many
items in it and so
it doesn't contain itself and then here
are some sets that do contain themselves
the set of all sets that contains itself
the set of all non-singleton sets yeah
that set contains itself because there
are many non-singleton sets and so that
set the set of all non-singleton sets
has many members and so it's a
non-singleton set so because that set
meets its own condition it is inside of
itself or the set of all sets that have
been mentioned in this room this room
which is an endless black abyss from
which i am speaking to you right now up
until right now that set did not include
itself but i just mentioned it so now it
does here's the next thought that
russell had in england in 1901. okay
let's take all those sets that do
contain themselves let's collect all of
them together and make another set out
of them the set of sets that contain
themselves now we've got a set of those
we'd write it like this the set of all
x's such that x is a set that contains
itself now let's take all of the sets
that do not contain themselves collect
them together make a set out of those
russell thinks to himself in 1901 as
he's barreling toward a paradox that's
going to blow up the whole project to
form the foundation of mathematics and
all of science this set that includes
all of those is the set of all sets that
do not contain themselves and we'd write
that like this the set of all x's such
that x is a set that does not contain
itself and then
something happened he realized a problem
and he wrote this problem in a letter in
1902 on june 16th to fraga and fraga
received the letter this is what the
letter really looked like fraga got the
letter and it broke him physically he
had a breakdown and had to be
hospitalized upon reading this two-page
letter and the letter asked this
question the set of all sets that do not
contain themselves this set does it
contain itself
here it is again the set of all x's the
set of all things such that x is a set
that does not contain itself does this
set contain itself well let's go through
both possibilities
if it does
then this set is in here it's in itself
and the only way to be in there is to
meet this condition the condition of not
containing oneself so if this set does
contain itself well then it meets this
condition and this condition says that
it doesn't contain itself if it does
contain itself
then it doesn't
and consider the alternative possibility
if it doesn't contain itself then it
meets the condition it's a set that
doesn't contain itself so if it doesn't
contain itself it meets the condition
and then it's in there which means it
contains itself so
if this set doesn't contain itself then
it does contain itself
if it doesn't then it does and if it
does
then it doesn't so
this set both contains itself and
doesn't contain itself and that's just a
contradiction so set theory doesn't work
that's the paradox now you might be
thinking oh okay well that's no problem
set theory was just some made-up rules
right that's how math is we just make
things up axioms are stipulated which is
to say made-up claims so we just made up
all these rules including rule 10 and
rule 11. and rule 11 is really the
source of the paradox once you let sets
contain themselves well then
you're going to be able to formulate
this set and this set is the one that
leads to the paradox so let's just
change the rules right yeah that's
exactly what russell tried to do he
tried to just change the rules of set
theory he made up some new rules and
according to his rules sets cannot
contain themselves
and that's what other mathematicians
doing set theory have done like the
zermillo frankel set theory that's a
version of set theory with some
restrictions they just get rid of rule
11. and of course if you get rid of rule
11 you say that sets cannot contain
themselves well then you also have to
get rid of rule 1 unrestricted
composition or the axiom of unrestricted
comprehension or whatever you want to
call it so that's what all the
mathematicians do but
does that work
like
can we just change the rules back before
when we were going through all those
rules rule one and rule 2 and all the
way up to rule 11.
were we just making up the rules no we
didn't just make up the rules and so we
can't just change them that was me i
just said that what i'm going to argue
for the next i don't know two minutes is
that the rules of set theory are not
made-up rules they're real non-made-up
objective rules that already exist and
they govern perhaps one of the most
fundamental practices of human existence
and that is
predication now i have to teach you some
linguistics this is going to take i
don't know 60 seconds 90 seconds
something like that once i've done that
i'm going to regenerate russell's
paradox and show that it was never a
paradox just for
set theory it's a paradox for all of
language and thought itself let's go
here is a sentence garfield is a cat it
contains four words grammatically
speaking though it has two essential
parts it has this first part which is
called the subject of the sentence and
it has this second part is a cat which
is called the predicate the subject is
what the sentence is about it's about
garfield the cat and the predicate says
something of garfield it says that
garfield has a certain characteristic
and that characteristic is being a cat
lebron is the subject of this sentence
he's the thing that the sentence is
about and dunks
here we go
is the predicate we can say that
predicates are true of
certain subjects so the predicate is a
cat is true of garfield and the
predicate dunks is true of lebron and
it's not true of me
what was the relationship between sets
and objects
the relation was containment sets
contain objects the objects are in the
sets what is the relation or the
relationship between predicates and
subjects
being true of predicates are true of or
a predicate is true of a subject what
i'm going to do now is i'm going to
leverage this similarity to try to
regenerate russell's paradox but now
it's not with some made-up rules of set
theory but with some very much not made
up rules of predication
and predication let me just remind you
is just the practice of saying
things about things so the practice of
predication is ubiquitous it is utterly
widespread we do this constantly we do
it linguistically all the time out loud
and almost every thought we have
predicates something of something
remember rule number one unrestricted
composition for set theory that rule was
the rule that there's a set for any
imaginable collection of a thing or of
things well that rule seems like it just
is true of predication also there is a
predicate for any imaginable
characteristic of a thing anything that
you can say about something there's a
predicate for that of course of course
there is and those rules of set theory
that allowed russell in 1901 to generate
his paradox those rules of set theory
the relevant ones they're just true of
predication too rule number 10 of
predication you can predicate things of
predicates just like you can have sets
of sets well that's true you can
predicate things of predicates here's a
perfectly grammatical english sentence
is a cat sounds funny yeah sure kind of
it does kind of sound funny when you
think about it is a cat is the cat is
your cat sure
it sounds funny in this sentence the
predicate is a cat is functioning as the
subject of the sentence sounds funny in
this sentence is the predicate and it's
saying something about the subject which
is the predicate is a cat sure we can do
that that's a perfectly meaningful thing
to do
in any natural language we can predicate
things of predicates yes we can can you
smell where this is going
predicates can be true of themselves
just like sets can contain themselves is
this right
i think it is consider for example the
sentence is a cat is a cat is that true
no because is a cat is a predicate
so it doesn't have a tail it doesn't
have fur
is a cat is not a cat but what about
this one is a predicate is a predicate
yes that's true is a predicate is a
predicate it is and that's a case where
the predicate is a predicate is true of
itself it says of itself that it's a
predicate and it's right so
rule number 11 predicates can be true of
themselves some predicates of course are
not true of themselves like is a cat we
already saw that is a cat is not a cat
so that predicate is not true of itself
dunks dunks doesn't dunk dunks is a
predicate so it can't play basketball it
can't dunk so it's not true to say that
dunks dunks no false tastes like chicken
that's a predicate something can taste
like chicken does taste like chicken
taste like chicken no it doesn't taste
like chicken is a predicate so it
doesn't taste like anything but then
you've got plenty of predicates that are
true of themselves is a predicate is a
predicate so is a predicate is true of
itself is a string of words is a string
of words yes it is so that predicate is
true of itself typically comes at the
end of a sentence well typically comes
at the end of a sentence does typically
come at the end of a sentence so
that predicate is true of itself now
let's try to make a predicate
that is true of
all of the predicates that are true of
themselves and that predicate just is is
true of itself is true of itself is true
of all of the predicates that are true
of themselves fine nothing wrong with
that predicate but then what if we tried
to make a predicate that's true of all
of the predicates that are not true of
themselves that predicate would be is
not true of itself and now we're gonna
generate the paradox i can't write this
in a letter to gottlob fraga because
gotlobfrega is dead but i'm writing it
in a video to you here's the question
is not true of itself this predicate
is it true of itself
let's go through both possibilities
if it is true of itself well then
what does it say about itself it says
that it's not true of itself so
if this predicate is true of itself then
it's not true of itself
if it is then it isn't what about the
alternative
if this predicate is not true of itself
then it's not true of itself
but then it meets the condition
set out
in itself it meets it has this
characteristic specified by by the
predicate it's not true of itself so if
it's not true of itself well then it's
true of itself
if it is true of itself then it's not
true of itself and not true just means
false so
if it is true of itself then it's false
of itself and if it's false of itself
then it's true of itself so it's both
true
and false which is a contradiction and
this isn't a paradox that we can just
escape by declaring that there is no
rule 11. in the case of set theory yeah
maybe we could just declare that sets
cannot contain themselves but in the
case of predication which is just
talking
in the case of saying things about
things we can't just declare that
predicates cannot be true of themselves
because they can this rule 11 this just
is true and once you give me rule 11 i'm
gonna generate the paradox this is a
paradox that we can't escape
you